hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen and
today I am watching The Mighty Ducks I
was talking with Walter who said that
this would be a good choice for tamarins
ever seen and so I'm excited it's a
diaphragm I always end up really loving
sports films whether they win or they
lose there's this really heartwarming
message of teamwork at the end generally
that makes you feel good and makes you
want to enjoy the film it's just the
getting to the end that usually takes me
a while to like jump on board with
love's Cool Runnings Rudy that was a
right wasn't that a sports
I don't gravitate towards sports films
so it will be interesting to see if this
catches my interest very excited to jump
in let's do it
ducks duh
[Music]
oh my god that was so boring y'all grew
up with this red one
aha how did you watch this as a kid as a
kid I'd be like no I will have none of
this buffoonery know starts off on this
dream sequence where our lead character
is like the last one to get a goal and
it's like it's all up to you and the
coaches like you're not only gonna let
yourself down if you don't get this you
let everybody down
he's like oh better get this goal
but he doesn't get it and he like falls
to his knees and he looks up and
everyone's super disappointed and it's
like wow well your ruins Christmas from
your one your one missed goal when
you're six years old that that event by
the way let him to never play hockey
again and here we are current day
flash-forward he's a jerk ass lawyer
because of course he is this is a 90s
film and he gets a DUI because that's
what happened to jerk ass lawyers and
also just anyone who drinks and drives
don't do it kids
anyways he has to do a bunch of
community service and instead of making
him do something that's like difficult
or like I know that bothered me they
were like you can you can go coach
children even though you endangered
everyone's lives when you were drunk on
the road but yeah yeah go for it go uh
coach some kids there is something super
Disney about that though where it's like
oh man for community service I have to
coach kids I hate kids they're barely
human the line he says he's so bland as
an actor he's so bland
he's like a Manny sandwich on white
bread with extra mayonnaise when they
were going in for the first day of
shooting the director was like can you
make it a face where you like like
you're kind of worried but not too
worried like like bland worried and he's
like oh yeah sure let me give it a try
and sight the director was like yeah and
just do that the entire time not too
worried cuz then like you care too much
it's like a whole thing just be like a
little worried and then do it
[Music]
while watching this I really didn't
understand he appeals this movie at all
it was like very boring it was very like
cut and paste is very just like you so
predictable and like just you don't care
about this lead character at all the
kids are fine but you don't you do not
care about the lead character and it's
like a people love this movie right like
I don't oh my god I am the asshole here
it's me
people are gonna hate me more than
they already do
I'm just uncultured film swine all right
it's my fault let's just move on so for
a while he's still coaching the kids
like the dick lawyer that he is and
having them cheat and take a fall and
just bad scummy scum of the earth kind
of thinks and the kids aren't having it
they're like you're an actual jerk he's
like I don't care I'm a lawyer then he
goes to his really cute sweet old
Scandinavian friends I think he was
Scandinavian and the guys like just
teach him for the love of it man used to
love it come on bring some of that back
then he starts coaching them better he
gets his firm to support him and sponsor
them give him $15,000 wow that's a lot
of money holy that's great good that's a
good deed you did a good thing man
hooray they just keep going back to this
storyline where he wants to skate and
you get the sense that he's maybe almost
30 I guess that's what I was kind of
getting and he hasn't skated since then
so you get this like montage of him
getting back on the ice and skating
again and then
you have him like he's like dreaming of
playing still and it's like I know that
this is Disney and I know what a
buzzkill of me to say but if you can't
get over something that happened 20 25
years ago when you were like seven years
old you need to go to therapy everyone's
gonna be like what a jerk Tamara it just
seems very dramatic how they said it I
also know it's connected to his dad's
death his dad died around the same time
he lost the big game he was seven and so
I understand I'm not a complete jerk not
like him when he was a lawyer I think
the reason why I have such a negative
view of this film too is because of one
aspect of the film they recruit this
character from the Hawks which is their
rival team they recruit him on a
technicality he's been playing with them
all season long it's like the seven
eight year old dude I don't know how old
these guys are bad with H maybe they're
like 10 13 I had no idea but they're
kids and they just want to play peewee
hockey and he's like you have to leave
your team now and come play with us the
dads like he would rather not played and
play with you all like shows up to the
game still wearing a Hawks Jersey even
though he has son is on the duck it's
crazy all the parents take this wages
anyways stuck the kid is like well I
just just want to play hockey so like
any way that I can play hockey would be
really cool and so like the Hawks all
those kids are dicks and so they like
desert them and like spit on him and get
him hurt in the last game and and then
the Ducks are like you're a hawk you'll
never be a dead knitter than that and
like a super me too I mean this poor kid
is just like this is not my fault this
adult on a technicality made me switch
teams my friends are on that team now I
have to be part of this team who hate me
and all in the technicality I was trying
to play peewee hockey it's crazy and it
really bothered me the parents taking it
way too seriously is probably you know
honestly a little accurate my dad and
brother played Little League
so maybe our Redux or what what an odd
sentence for a human to say though I
will say the part that I enjoyed the
very most is there is a girl on the team
and a guy on the team that are flirting
with each other the whole time and at
one point the guy who is in that
flirtatious little duo says to another
player remember man soft hands
concentration not strength he goes over
to the girl and wing setter like hell
yeah oh yeah you get it you get it you
got it you're good ten years old he's
already knows here he goes so then they
win the whole playoffs and the whole
championship and it's so so fun is it
it's fun to see the team work and then
working together and then you know
working they've been doing this for two
hours and now we get to see the final
product and they won and they get
improved and it was great but like man
to get to this point was such a drag
this is all Walters faults Walter said
that I should watch this you go tell
Walter right now you go tell him this
was a bad idea
shame Walter shame shame I've never seen
Game of Thrones sight I only know that
that is a reference not like what it's
referencing first prediction was you'll
think Emilio Estevez is somewhat miscast
in this yes holy moly that would have
made the movie so much more enjoyable if
it had just been cast differently with
him I so I hate saying stuff like that I
hate when I don't enjoy an actor
personally I don't like harping on other
actors I know people don't enjoy my
performances and that sucks but
yeah oh oh you know yeah you'll love the
girl making a score using her figure
skating skills I did like that that was
cute it was also very reminiscent of
last week I did last World Report too
and it was very reminiscent of like the
girl using her gymnastics to kind of do
it a little kitschy but it was fun I
didn't hate it in this as much as I
hated it in that so that's saying
something
you will remember Emilio Estevez was
kind of a big deal once I I hope this
doesn't surprise anyone because it's me
but I don't know who that is does he fit
in
I'm 130 Oh The Breakfast Club I haven't
seen The Breakfast Club before Maximum
Overdrive never seen it repo man never
seen it The Outsiders never seen it
feels oh no people are gonna hate this
reaction I wish that I like to this more
than I actually did it's okay not to
like things it is okay that being said
check out next week for Suicide Squad
because I have some unpopular opinions
about being joyful through most of that
film thank you so so much for watching
you all I will see you next week
quack-quack-quack bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you